hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play gary dark secrets
my name is mark Klein we're walking down
the bridge with the weird moving
chain-link things alright anyway so we
spawn just about every single monster
that will ever spawn on this level
I think I'm not exactly sure anymore at
and how many monsters there are but I'm
gonna keep going
I forget what I need I need aqua regia
that's the only ingredient I'm missing
from my little potion in my explosive
mixture here and I guess i need to find
maybe some form of AA it's okay
bring it on who was who wants some
anybody didn't think so that's right
I'm too bear oh yeah I was in a library
area and I remember there being a bunch
of stuff around me but I didn't get a
chance to see ah this is it because her
monsters literally chasing me in a
circle the entire time so I'm gonna look
carefully now any movable oh oh yeah I
remember now oh oh oh it's is oh yeah
here ah this is the lab area I put a box
on this guy
oh you is ugly
oh you saw oh I'll put you nice back
normal all right it was ever a place for
our queries yeah let's hope that it's
here and not in that dark room or the
Red Room body parts yeah
rody anyway someone exploded and well
actually let me get this started here
start to the burner a burner now I need
to add aqua regia and Cana mine okay I
just need to go get the aqua region
alright let me check there was other
place over here too right okay
alright I just I think I just got to go
in the Red Room
Oh aah aah chairs what are you doing
what are you do it opened
wait when did it open always been
watching
Oh Oh walk crawl chairs you freaking me
out okay
seems normal
I feel compelled to step inside a
smaller
huh okay all right we're guessing this
nothing so yeah okay okay all right okay
nothing happened nothing happened
everything went perfectly okay all right
oh yeah I was running down this other
hall and then the monster came and I
couldn't go that way
that's right oh nothing happened
it was so disconcerting and yet nothing
happened
okay I think I ran down here oh yeah I
ran in here
oh those were I got the poison gland
there was nothing behind here they
old-line what yeah here and now looking
for something I'm a little freaked out
today because for the first time in a
long time I had a nightmare and I don't
even remember what it was about but all
I remember is that I was in a lot of
pain and screaming okay yeah I ran down
here and this is where and I was I was
running down the hallways or something
and something was like hitting me in the
back I don't know but all I know is that
it was hitting me and it hurt like a
[ __ ] and I knew that if I
stopped and turned around I would die so
I just had to keep running down the hall
I don't know what the deal was but it
was the freakiest thing I've ever done
in my life okay I came in here now I've
gone in a big circle so someone find a
freaking dr. Asia it must be down one of
these hallways that I've been
god I don't know it freaked me out I
just woke up to record some more so like
I've been playing these four games for a
while now and I just I haven't gotten
nightmares like I swear the last time I
I've had had to been at least a year ago
oh man okay
it's weird because there's this one and
then there's the one with the iron
maiden in nothing happens down them I
don't think I've gotten anything from
them so it's all about immersion with
these games
if you feel immersed that's when it
really impacts yet for some reason I'm
feeling it now okay this is the hallway
connecting to the dungeon which connects
to my old cell this one's still locked
ah where the Fricke frak is the aqua
regia alright let me take another close
look at this shelving maybe I'll go back
to the lab area okay oh maybe let me
look at the bookshelves up here I don't
think that note I got told me where
anything was it just told me what to get
okay
okay I'm looking I'm looking I'm looking
behind the barrel I'm looking behind the
shelving don't see anything nothing on
the table nothing I knocked over and my
run away from the monsters behind the
barrel I'm just not seeing anything okay
I guess this is okay because this is
like the first time I've gotten lost in
this entire custom story so I'm not
really a big deal let me double-check
the rebbe area I was in I sit behind the
iron
baby okay that music is freaking getting
to me I swear it's just the same thing
looping over and over again
is it the normal amnesia music I don't
even remember that okay I went back this
way the lion this is where I got the
poison gland I can't go back there can't
go back there I know I can't I got the
calamine the only place I haven't
double-checked is where I started I've
checked the cells
oh man that music is getting to me shot
up with the music okay what's down this
hole I go down this way it's in this
room
no I've been in here let me double-check
ah yes there it is okay this place oh
man how did I miss that
let's get out of here I don't care okay
oh I swear some days you have good days
some days you have bad days this ain't
proven to be one of the good days oh man
okay now I had the Aqua Rita here get
that put the poison gland yeah I've done
this before
see there we go open this up some sort
of extractor let's extract her chunk
okay all right good good good good good
good
explosives now where was I supposed to
put this
[Music]
didn't sound like the most sincere of
acting seriously what was deal with this
area here
I don't know ah the music again that
[ __ ] music it's just non-stop
huh-huh-huh
Oh
oh I don't know I don't know oh please a
[ __ ] deal are you [ __ ] kidding me
I don't need this right now
okay here it is what the [ __ ] was that
oh okay whatever can't use the same this
way okay I know this is where it okay
ah [ __ ] it out okay oh I'm not I'm not
doing well
see it's not it's not the monsters
anymore that get me it's [ __ ]
everything else I can deal with monsters
I can deal I can deal with monsters
because they're real and they're
tangible and they're there and I can
know ah I'll post it right away from
them but when you [ __ ] with me and you
go back and you uh and when you just
throw a never mind things that aren't
there [ __ ] mannequins are everywhere
he's just increasing the number of
mannequins I swear
laughs [ __ ] you this is smash smash your
[ __ ]
huh huh huh oh oh I don't wanna I don't
wanna I don't wanna I don't wanna I
don't wanna I don't wanna I don't wanna
I don't wanna I don't wanna I don't
wanna okay
Oh God [ __ ] you okay
god dammit all [ __ ] out run really
really oh you piece of [ __ ]
Oh [ __ ] you've gotta be
[ __ ] me god damn it
[ __ ] moose man Jesus Christ get out
my way boxes epically jump [ __ ] who
the [ __ ] is he [ __ ] hell I can't deal
with this right now
I can't [ __ ] deal with this right now
Oh God oh man oh man
[Music]
goddamn
I'm not ah man I'm not I'm not doing
well Oh
moving statues animated Oh God oh good
job
alright I'm forgetting myself good job
guys Gary
dark secrets holy crap that was amazing
honestly um I'm okay I'm okay alright
men
Gary dark secrets that was honestly one
of the best I've ever played that rivals
the original campaign I mean nothing
will touch the original campaign in my
eyes because the first one I did and it
was just so perfect except for there was
a lot of things you throw rocks at I'm
hoping that and these young machine for
pigs is gonna be beyond phenomenal but
this was amazing everybody go playing if
they have a donation plays page if they
have a website please contribute I still
hear the running screaming in the
background there if they have something
like that just give them something to
encourage them because I saw those
chapter one so they have chapter two
please donate to them they're great it's
fantastic go play for yourself don't
take my word for it
get yourself immersed in the story and
these is real cheap on Steam so go play
yourself oh man as far the hamdi the
Humble Indie bundle - so you could have
gotten it for like a dollar if you were
cheap like that but or you had no money
that too but anyway oh thank you
everybody so much for watching
whoa I think I'm gonna take a break from
me in Asia for a bit just for multiple
reasons anyway but oh man I'm gonna go
look at pictures of kitties go play with
my puppy anyway thank you all so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye